[Music]
the fairchild republic a-10
lightning-bolt
or simply the hog is one of the most
iconic planes in the US Air Force a
plane developed in the middle of the
Cold War with a specific type of warfare
in mind if the Cold War turned hot one
area was destined to become a
battleground a 50 kilometer corridor of
lowland Valley's called the Fulda gap
where any invading troops would be
channeled on their march from East
Germany to West Germany it was the
shortest route to France Frankfurt and
the strategically important Rhine River
if war broke out this corridor would be
a vital region to secure and each side
of the Fulda gap was defended by
armoured divisions to cope with this
threat environment the u.s. developed an
operational doctrine called air land
battle and the a-10 was developed as a
vital component of this strategy a
low-flying tank killer which would work
closely with the troops on the ground to
break up enemy formations at the front
while high-flying bombers harassed the
supply lines at the rear the a-10 was a
plane designed specifically for the role
of close air support close air support
is exactly that close close to friendly
forces and close to unfriendly forces it
requires a plane to be capable of
absorbing a great deal of damage as they
come under fire and to be incredibly
accurate where its weapons to avoid
friendly fire a plane with this role
needs some unique qualities it needs to
be available at a moment's notice in an
ever-evolving battlefield troops could
need support without warning and because
of this the plane needs to be nearby and
ready to go this means working from
forward bases that may not necessarily
have all the infrastructure and
equipment that other planes need to
operate
it's survivability needs to be
in class flying this close to the ground
is going to result in every man with
weapon taking potshots at the plane as a
result the plane needs to be capable of
dealing with small arms machine guns
anti-aircraft guns and even missiles a
tense frequently limp back to their base
would damage so severe that they would
have downed another plane with parts of
their wings ripped off with an engine
taken out and hydraulics on operational
and coming with this the plane needs to
be simple and cheap to manufacture the
air force made it clear from the
beginning in a battle of cost versus
performance cost would be prioritized in
an all-out war with the Soviets quantity
and ease of manufacturing was going to
be a huge factor like the Sherman and
the t-34 tanks which were so influential
in world war ii a future war between the
Soviets and the US was expected to be
won by whoever could out manufacture and
maintain their equipment this plane was
intended to be a cheap and rugged
warhorse it needed to be made with
readily available off-the-shelf parts
so maintenance crews could easily
interchange parts to repair damage
quickly and at a low cost
contractors bidding for the
manufacturing contract needed to
consider all of these factors and
designed the entire plane around the
primary urnament which was chosen before
the design process started the General
Electric gau-8/a a gun whose sound is so
recognizable it has become a meme the
gun takes up a significant portion of
the plane's internal volume at nearly 6
metres long fitting snugly below the
pilot the largest part of the gun is the
ammo drum which typically holds 1,150 30
millimeter rounds the rounds are
delivered to the 7 rotating barrels
along a linkless shoot system which also
pulls the shell casings back into the
ammo drum after firing to prevent the
expanded shells from damaging the plane
the belt system and the rotating cam
firing system of the barrels are both
driven by a hydraulic motor which is
powered by two independent hydraulic
systems onboard there are two separate
hydraulic systems to ensure redundant
see in operation and both run the gun
the left and right hydraulic systems are
pressurized by two identical engine
driven pumps on the left and right
engine if an engine is lost or one of
the hydraulic lines is broken than the
controls powered by those hydraulics
ceased to work
however the plane has been designed to
allow it to continue flying on only one
hydraulic system as both elevators both
ailerons and one rudder have hydraulic
power after loss of either hydraulic
lines ensuring powered control of pitch
roll and yaw even after the loss of a
single hydraulic system if both are lost
the plane can switch to a manual
reversion flight control system where
the controls can be operated without
power assists which is difficult to say
the least but it can allow the pilot to
land the plane safely or at the very
least allow them to get into safe
airspace to eject this kind of
redundancy can be found in every
component of the a10 to increase
survivability the landing gear is
retracted by the LES system only but it
can be extended by both and in the event
neither system is available the wing
mounted landing gear doesn't actually
retract all the way into the pharynx
which allows the plane to land with
landing gear retracted with only
moderate damage to the plane
protecting the control mechanisms
through redundancy is just one component
of increasing survivability the fuel
tanks are self-sealing on the lower
portions and are filled with foam to
prevent explosions the a-10 like all
planes can fly with significant armor
covering every portion of the plane so
they just protect the most vital
component on the plane the stick
operator otherwise known as the pilot
who sits inside a titanium tub which is
reported to be capable of absorbing
direct hits from armor-piercing rounds
up to 23 millimeters the canopy is also
made from ballistic glass capable of
taking hits from small-arms but this
isn't the type of plane to be flying
upside down over the battlefield this is
more for shrapnel from anti-aircraft
fire and missiles
the a-10 also carries more chaff and
flares than any US air
legacy fighter chaff is radar reflective
material which confuses radar controlled
missiles while flares confuse
heat-seeking missiles with four
dispensers located in the landing gear
pods and another four on the outer wing
tips for a total of sixteen across both
wings which can be triggered
automatically by radar and laser
detection systems on the nose and
wingtips of the plane or simply fired
manually by the pilot one of the most
striking features of the a-10 is its
strange engine placement and tail
configuration and this too was a design
feature to thwart enemies with
heat-seeking missiles the engines and
tail were arranged like this to mask the
infrared signature of the hot exhaust of
the plane which could be used to lock on
to the plane by IR missiles on the
ground the tail would look more at home
on a world war two bomber which were
designed to be stable stability was an
important part of the a tense design the
large vertical stabilizers helped keep
the plane on target as it fires its
insanely powerful gun the gun is mounted
directly on the centerline of the plane
to minimize the effect of the recoil
pushing the plane off target the recoil
force at 40 4.5 kilonewtons is so
powerful that it effectively halves the
planes for thrust as each of the eight
ends General Electric t-34 engines
produces just 41 kilonewtons of thrust
but the plane fires in such short bursts
typically one to two seconds that the
pilot doesn't need to worry about
Salling the high engines mounted behind
the wings also reduced the amount of
dirt and dust that can enter the engines
from forward-operating base runways
which can be just dirt runways a lot of
design choices were made to allow the
plane to operate from remote airfields
like this smaller military planes like
this don't typically have auxilary power
units which are small secondary engines
that large planes like airliners have
you can see the exhaust of these little
hidden engines in the tails of airliners
these engines allow the plane to start
its main engines without external help
and help run functions like electricity
generation and
hydraulic fluid pumps but it's a
necessary weight for most small aircraft
and they usually use some other way to
get the engine spinning sometimes this
results in the plane relying on ground
equipment which the a-10 cannot depend
on and so an AP was installed between
the two potted engines you can see the
exhaust of the APU just underneath the
nacelle x' here some of the most
interesting design challenges arose from
the sheer power of the aircraft's gun
the gun spits out so much burnt anon
burnt propellant that they actually lost
an early model in 1978 after exhaust gas
from the gun ignited and starved the
engines of oxygen to deal with this some
design changes were made first a small
gas scoop was placed underneath the
barrels to suck in some of that exhaust
the chemical mixture of the round
propellant was changed to increase the
flashes of present levels this in turn
caused secondary problems as the new
chemical mixture caused residue to build
up on the cockpit windows and a canopy
washer was needed which simply sprayed
the washing fluid onto the canopy and
the slipstream did the rest of the work
circuitry was also added to force the
engine ignition system to continually
fire while the gun trigger was being
pulled so that in the event a flame out
occurred the engine could rekindle its
flame immediately the gau-8 avenger is a
monstrous machine designed to wreak
havoc on those Soviet tanks attempting
to push through allied lines to do this
they need heavy armor-piercing rounds
the rounds are truly massive at 30
millimetres and sprinkled throughout
these rounds are rounds made of
aluminium with a depleted uranium core
uranium is insanely dense at nineteen
point one g/cm^3 lead in comparison is
eleven point three grams per centimeter
cubed and iron is 7.9 this density gives
the round more kinetic energy for
armor-piercing the depleted uranium also
ablates material in a way that self
sharpens the projector while tungsten
which is slightly denser than uranium
tends to mushroom out and doles itself
upon impact
there is currently 700 thousand metric
tons of depleted uranium stored as
uranium hexafluoride in huge storage
cylinders across America costing uranium
enrichment facilities a great amount in
maintenance
they are simply delighted when someone
gets it off their hands and fires it at
high speed into a country thousands of
miles away it's a cheap and freely
available resource and has the perfect
material properties for armor-piercing
but the efficacy of using depleted
uranium is obviously not good
many war-torn regions have blamed its
use for elevated cases of cancer the
a-10 has been under constant threat of
retirement detractors have pushed from
the very start that the plane is not
needed first it was the f-16 which
should take over its job and now it's
the f-35 and both sides of the argument
have valid points the f-16 and a10 can
carry similar amounts of ordnance into
the battlefield if needed
both have 11 hard points where the
carrying capacity over 7.2 tonnes but
attaching heavy equipments to its wings
negates the biggest advantage of the
f-16 its maneuverability and ability to
conserve kinetic energy in dogfights the
f-16 was designed to be a multi-role
fighter while the a-10 was designed for
one job and one job only getting down
and dirty and taken some punches like
Rocky
while modern planes like the f-35 were
designed to be more like Muhammad Ali
bobbing weaving illusive striking and
moving out of the enemy's range before
they can react the two planes were
designed in completely different eras
with completely different military
doctrine in mind and trying to compare
the two without acknowledging that is
silly the f-35 is designed to carry a
small payload of weapons in its internal
weapons Bay while stealth is a high
priority but it can carry just as much
as the f-16 when air superiority is
established it's a multi-role fighter
designed for the modern battlefield
ultimately the a-10 found a role in wars
like Iraq and Afghanistan where the
threat level and sophistication of enemy
weaponry was relatively low like the
battles expected in the folder gap in
the 1980s
the a-10 persists today because it
excels in its role as a close air
support vehicle and it's low cost of
running compared to other military
planes has kept it competitive allowing
us to be in the vanguard for military
operations today he planed the infantry
can see coming over the horizon like
Gandalf arriving into helms deep to lift
the siege it's become an iconic aircraft
among the soldiers on the ground a bond
has formed between us and the infantry
it protects but just as the a-10 was
created in preparation for an
anticipated next-generation war the f-35
was created with future Wars in mind
where the threat environment will be so
dense that simply being able to take a
punch won't save us the nature of close
air support has continually evolved over
the past century in world war ii
tactical air forces were created
specifically for providing close air
support to the troops landing in
Normandy on d-day range for these
fighters was a major tactical issue and
within 24 hours of the first men landing
in Normandy three new emergency landing
strips had been created off the beaches
which would allow the Allies to extend
their fighter bomber range and prevent a
fierce counter-attack by the Germans
from overwhelming the small toehold the
Allies managed to carve out in Normandy
I explored these vital logistical
challenges in a future episode of the
logistics of d-day that will be out next
month
these airfields were primarily built to
extend the reach of Allied aerial
support as ground troops push forward
however as the front line progressed
many were converted to supply depots
emergency evacuation posts and heavy
bomber airfields others were simply
abandoned and allowed to return to
farmland over time there are hidden
traces of these remains littered all
over Normandy you can learn more about
them and get access to the entire
logistics of d-day series by signing up
to curiosity stream for just $19.99 for
the entire year
here you can watch the hidden traces
documentary about modern archaeological
digs uncovering remnants of the eighth
decade old battlefield and you will get
free access to nebula the home of the
logistics of d-day series and many more
original series from some of YouTube's
best educational creators like Tom Scott
went over production sentirse
1999 for an entire year of access to
curiosity stream with thousands of
award-winning documentaries and access
to nebula is a fantastic price and will
help educational creators to continue
creating their content without the
constraints of the YouTube algorithm as
always thanks for watching and thank you
to all my patreon supporters if you'd
like to see more from me the links to my
Instagram Twitter subreddit and discord
server are below
you